you were doing you before you do you was
even a thing yeah just even just
following your career there was you had
an unapologetic quality to you that made
people want to aspire to be you not just
as a chef but as that guy yeah I think
you know that was part of my background
in terms of how I grew up with that
level of respect and hunger to succeed
it wasn't become famous it was just to
be brutally honest and I think more
importantly to respect what I've got
yeah I had a tough upbringing and I I
worked so hard to get out of that to
provide you know a different level of
life and then you get on that treadmill
all of a sudden I'll have you control
this thing for me
I say to the kids on a daily basis you
gotta find your passion and don't do
what I do don't worry about becoming a
chef you've got to find your passion and
the the upbringing do you still have
these flashes where you look around and
everything that you've achieved in any
bookstore your face on a TV show you're
all over the joint do you ever just sit
down and go god how the hell did I get
here yeah that's a good question Roz and
I'm not good at self reflective you know
I know I had an extraordinary time a
year ago when I did an amazing online
master class cooking yeah and this
director just like opened me up I was
you know midnight at home cooking at
home and that's all I want to do I think
really yeah you know and get away from
the distractions so if I can focus on
that and he said look you know such a
hands-on chef who doesn't cook when
you're not there
and I'm saying not the same people do
when I am there and that's what I've
managed to do I suppose over the period
of 10 years because if I didn't then I'd
probably kill myself nobody a young man
yeah you know you have really turned
Twitter into something special which is
people tweet you their disasters and you
critique them as only you can
yeah I want some nice opposed I get
tough when they blocked my feed up with
that crap am i right do you give tough
though I mean I do get tough then I feel
sorry for them and then I think what you
know some of the stuff they send me is
shocking it looks like the inside of my
granddad's bloody underpass so I'm like
no
yeah let's do this again I want to
actually quick without Gabriel because
you offer Gabriel the education yes
you've got the potential to be huge in
this industry you just need the right
training so I am personally gonna send
you to Connery school
[Music]
I look at this young guy who was unique
and had this incredible palette he was
working at Chipotle and what struck me
was that this guy's got no training but
the magic that he was producing he was
only young I think 17 18 years of age we
have a we have a video here an update
for you that Gabriel I went to us you
want to hit play oh hi guys it's been
quite a ride since the end of the show
I've enjoyed being in class being here
in school everybody's really pushing me
and people are going back and watching
the episodes it's life-changing
yeah extraordinary things I mean if that
guy can be that good without training
yeah you have any idea what's gonna
become incredible when he's trains my
doors open so what what we talk about 40
$50,000 education fees for me I can do
that but it wasn't about the money it is
about that guy's potential so spotting
that talent in him it's really weird
within the first two weeks of meeting
him I spotted a little bit of his
vulnerability me inside him I felt that
was me at 19 insecure amazing you know
driven but we will need somewhere in our
life that bit of mentorship and I've
never ever shown away from that in terms
of what it did for me